only on CBS this morning we are hearing
from the American tourist who was
kidnapped in Uganda no captive for
nearly five days in part two of our
interview with Kimberley Endicott she is
sharing the story of her release for the
very first time and how this experience
still haunts her I remember laying down
on the ground and I remember hearing JP
say oh my god at my exhaustion Kimberley
Endicott and her guy JP Marengo Ramez Oh
had been walking with their captors
across the Ugandan border to the more
unstable Democratic Republic of Congo at
one point I'm asked to get up and I turn
and look and they've made a tent for me
out of tarps and a mosquito net which I
remember that was the moment where I
thought why are they taking such a good
care of me
that seems like a little piece of
humanity for you yes mm-hmm very much
this relationship starts with these
young men in the camp what do you mean
relationship uh I just start talking to
them like I'm talking to you mm-hmm
but all the while I'm watching these
young men drink water not from the river
but from a hole in the ground but they
have bottled water for me
they had bottled water for you yes and
they would drink from the hole in the
ground yep you ended up feeling
compassion for them a hundred percent
how could I not some would say how could
you
cuz that's their life mm-hmm it's not
really above living like an animal
that's their life if I survive this I
have a life to go back to that's their
life that does not condone what they did
not even close but I think most people
wouldn't have the compassion that you
have in this circumstances or the heart
that you have in this circumstances and
I marvel that you were able to do that
but nobody knows that until they're in
that situation
while a search effort was underway the
kidnappers began making calls to the
tour company demanding a ransom and
giving JP and Kimberley the phone at
points in the negotiations I was able to
call my daughter once they let me do
that my daughters besides herself of
course her mother's been kidnapped but
I'm I'm not beside myself I'm saying
okay we can't like we can't do this now
we let's get it together but tell
everybody what's happening tell everyone
what's happening because I don't know
what's being done so JP
and the captors are now trying to
negotiate with the tork right to get
money to get money okay right once they
were free it was reported across the
world the hunt for the perpetrators
continues along the Ugandan border
following five days of negotiations a
ransom was finally paid but the amount
and donor are unknown when they said
okay run you're free to go where were
they releasing you - there was the woman
from the Ugandan wildlife Authority from
what I was told
yeah is the one that met them with the
money mhm and she was then meeting us
with gentleman on a boda boda do you
know what a boat a boat it is no clue
it's a motorcycle the two freed captives
hopped on the motorcycle and finally
were driven to safety when we pulled
into a Shasha camp I realized just what
my government did for me mm-hmm and I
was overcome with shame for thinking
they didn't do anything and gratitude
like I've never felt in my life
somebody said something to you that's
quite profound what was that that those
young men were both my captors and my
protectors and they were you see it that
way - 100 % explained they could have
sold me to a different group when I went
out in the open they had guns that also
protected me it could have been so much
worse than it was
Kimberley has been back in the
States just over two weeks now but those
five days in early April still haunt her
do you relieve this experience yeah I
think a little less every day certain
things will trigger me we went for a
walk out at a nature area and it just
triggered me like nobody's business the
sound of our feet on the ground pushing
bushes out of my way and so I'm getting
in touch with that there's gonna be that
probably for a while do you believe that
it's safe to go to Uganda still I do I
do again you do I'm the exception to the
rule that was the other thing that
feeling of what this is going to do to
that country that is is run by their
people mm-hmm and those are immensely
friendly accommodating people mm-hmm
everyone in hospitality after you would
have a conversation the last thing they
said to you was please tell all of your
friends to come so what when all this is
said and done do you just look at this
as a ragtag team of people 100% and you
just happen to be in the wrong place at
the wrong time hopefully the right place
at the right time hopefully if something
beautiful is going to come out of this
that's where I have to hold my hope
she's amazing she has many thoughts and
when she said about the ransom she said
I know everybody wants know about the
ransom the ransom you know the demand
was for five hundred thousand to the
tour company she thinks but she doesn't
know for sure she thinks it was maybe
about thirty thousand she doesn't know
quite she still isn't sure who paid it
the kidnappers to to our knowledge into
her still remain at large people don't
know where they are but I mean she's
just very centered very grounded very
calm and just really in some ways feels
guilty that this happened because it
puts a taint she says on Uganda these
kidnappers 20 to 30 years old
she seemed to have deep Rivers of
something either spirituality or
whatever what she does for a living or
something that she was able to tap into
because she has amazing equanimity I
know she said she was triggered by her
walk but amazing equanimity in face of
all what she does for a living she's an
esthetician so she has her own business
that she's had for twenty four years and
I was
talking about yeah I've dried skin Geo's
you know when we were walking in the
sunlight I could tell your skin is quite
dry so she gave me a product I mean but
so she's feisty but she's also very
thoughtful she's also very loving very
kind I was really really impressed with
her Oh in the blanket did you guys
notice she was holding a blanket in her
lap and even when we went for oh there
it is
okay good thank you you went for a walk
giving around it she carries this
blanket with her
that blanket guys came from the vehicle
where she was kidnapped from oh wow and
I said I would think that that would be
triggering and upsetting too she said
oddly it's comforting because it
protected me it kept me warm it kept the
mosquitoes away so she looks at that as
something that really provides her with
some nurturing in a very surprising way
to me I like to hear express gratitude
not only for the US government but for
others oh she was very specific about
the role the US Embassy in Uganda and
Mike somebody named Mike who she's were
internally grateful for we saw him on
the video she couldn't say enough about
what the government has done nice and
everything Thanks